on poursuit avec le directeur du groupe
d'étude dans le management des
entreprises de l'aéronautique de l'uqam
mehran ebrahimi et bonsoir d'abord
mettant quelque chose au clair
air canada une entreprise privée depuis
la fin des années 80 est ce qu'elle a
l'obligation d'offrir des services
régionaux
air canada n'a pas l'obligation tentent
elles ont chassé dans la loi donc quand
vous avez dit c'est notre vie privée qui
prend ses décisions a parlé de
conditions qui sont quittés au moment de
la privatisation c'est dire le siège
social est à montréal et le service de
maintenance doit rester donc au québec
et à qui elle enfin montréal et pillé un
mini break en dehors de sa r15 à prendre
une décision dans le temps dans son
intérêt et dans sa dans l'intérêt de sa
pérennité je dirais selon vous c'est
permanent aux passagers comme décision
écoutez la situation je pense que c'est
très banal de le dire et c'est tellement
la crise dans la liesse était tellement
important de cette fois ci que toutes
les entreprises cherchent n'importe
quelle solution pour essayer de survivre
écoutez les entreprises comme air france
klm qui ont reçu de la part de nos
gouvernants
le prêt de 10 milliards d'euros cette
année à votre et 16 milliards de dollars
canadiens
eux aussi ils ont un nul il parle bien
de leur division 3 et vient des dizaines
et des dizaines de trajet dockers canada
sein qui n'a pas reçu de l'aide du
gouvernement
et d'ailleurs c'est incroyable comment
le gouvernement fédéral est absent dans
ce dossier là depuis le début que sa
chose
le retrait d'air canada dans les régions
que ça soit pour supporter le secteur
que ce soit par rapport à la fermeture
des frontières une silence radio de la
part du fédéral alors que ces cinq sous
sa juridiction
allons donc air canada voir un petit peu
dans ce sens là et je dirais un moment
donné si encore ses trajets là sont
rentables ceux ci 17 jamais été vraiment
de trajet une raie manta fait l'argent
avec les avec le service international
si vous voulez vous voyez darren excusez
moi monsieur vrais amis mais vous parlez
dead air canada quand même reçu de
l'aide via la subvention un canadien
d'urgence n'ont écouté ce programme là
ça n'a pas été un programme qui a eu
beaucoup de succès pour les grandes
entreprises
et après 10 à 15 % des entreprises par
rapport à la tente que le brevet fédéral
avait elle qui ont participé à ce
programme là pourquoi on deux raisons
d'abord parce que air canada avait des
frais fixes très élevés qui ne sont pas
les coups de salaire a par exemple si
vous avez un avion monocouloir 737 qui
est une cloués au sol
ça vous coûte après deux cent à trois
cent mille dollars par mois juste pour
les coûts de capteurs dos à dos et
avions là vous avez des répliques tout
maintenant c'est tout ça est aussi chère
canada la majorité des salaires sont
bien plus que les 54 mille dollars
c'est-à-dire le plafond que le
gouvernement fédéral donc contribuer
autrement dit air canada est obligé de
payer la différence payer les avantages
sociaux
c'est donc ça ce n'est pas quelque chose
qui est spécifique
si on regarde par exemple l'allemagne si
on regarde les états unis si on regarde
la france si on regarde l'australie tout
ça ils ont fait des programmes
spécifiques par rapport à chaque
compagnie aérienne et donc pour pour les
événements à ce que les financières sont
différents nous on n'a pas fait ça du
tout du tout il sera là bas et ça c'est
absolument
il accepta et la problématique des
liaisons régionales d'actes audience a
fait pas ses preuves depuis hier que les
régions dénoncent le prix ou les
services offerts par air canada
on va regarder un tableau qui nous
montre enfin plusieurs petits
transporteurs qu'on retrouve au québec
est-ce que c'est envisageable de penser
qu'un plus petit transporteur reprennent
le flambeau
dites-nous est ce qu'il ya quelqu'un là
train dans ces entreprises qu'elles
iraient à ses solides car c'est coûteux
ce genre de services aériens n'aurait
coûté il est évident que ces compagnies
la rando de service est intéressant
c'est vrai qu'ils connaissent le terrain
c'est vrai qu'ils connaissent les
régions isolées des pilotes mais c'était
un petit peu complémentaire par rapport
à ce qu'air canada faisait pour une
raison simple regardez l'âge moyen des
avions tous ces compagnies là présente
pascal quand on parle là l'âge c'est à
dire c'est des avions qui ont arrêté
d'être produit à la fin des années 80 90
donc ces avions là où plus de 25 ans 30
ans c'est pas avec la flotte d'ailleurs
que sas a donc régné tout cela parce
qu'elle est ça qu on va pouvoir le
faire c'est parce qu'elle vient
d'acquérir un saab 340 donc quatre
centres en pardon qui quittent acquis au
moins 20 ans et ça c'est une nouvelle
acquisition ils veulent remplacer des
avions pas encore plus anciens c'est pas
avec ses avions là à 20,7 à lyon à bord
un personnes à bord qu'on va pouvoir
remplacer air canada je pense qu'il faut
revenir un exercice comme avait fait un
travers plusieurs activités que ce sont
les états généraux que ça sonne comme ce
parlementaire tout par rapport à leur
apport au développement régional on a
regardé des pays comme la norvège une
partie de l'australie des pays qui ont
des espaces d'offres des distances très
grande mais dans cette population faible
et on a vu comment ces gens là ont
réussi de faire le transport aérien tel
levier de développement régional et nous
on ne fait pas tout simplement parce
qu'il n'ya pas d'entente
il n'y a pas de générer une
collaboration entre les acteurs locaux
il n'y aura pas à me priver pascan ou
n'importe qui d'autre qui pourra
remplacer air canada tout seul il va
falloir que ce soit les acteurs locaux
veulent que la soif de le gouvernement
fédéral le gouvernement provincial à
partir dans une structure comme en place
de façon permanente de rassemble durable
et chercher avec les appareils avec une
infrastructure qui ne permet pas c'est
pas avec des avions qui ont 30 ans 35
ans de deux parce que ça pour essayer de
régler cette question à monsieur
monsieur rémy c'est tout le temps qu'on
a mais ce que je comprends c'est que
l'aide gouvernementale dans québec
ottawa semble inévitable si rien ne
vient pas dans le portrait merci
beaucoup d'avoir été avec nous ce soir
on va suivre ce dossier de très près
merci ça plaise